why're plane wings angled backwards
today most planes have a swept wing
design and this helps the plane fly
faster but it wasn't always this way
let's look back in time and learn how
this technology was developed and what
we learned in the process back in 1941
most planes were designed with a
straight wing and the Lockheed p-38
lightning was no different the straight
wing design works well at lower speeds
but the p38 was not a slow plane and its
engineers quickly discovered that the
plane had major control issues in high
speed dives on November 5th 1941 a
Lockheed test pilot by the name of Ralph
Burton died when he lost control of his
aircraft this spurred a major
investigation headed by an engineer
called John stack he employed a special
type of photography called schlieren
photography to observe the air flow in a
high-speed wind tunnel and this is what
he saw as air passes over the wing the
air over the top of the airfoil
accelerates this is how the wing
generates lift this means that a wing
traveling at less than the speed of
sound can actually develop areas of
localized flow traveling faster than the
speed of sound and shock waves form at
these locations the shock waves will
reduce the lift and increase the drag on
the wing the speed at which shock waves
begin to appear is called a critical
Mach number and Ralph Verdun reached the
speeds during his high speed test dive
so why did this cause a crash as the
speed of his plane increased even
further the airflow from the surface of
the wings separated due to the shock
wave formation this separated flow
actually increased the lift on the tail
wing and this combined with the reduced
lift on the wing caused the p38 to enter
an even deeper dive one that was very
difficult to escape from John stack
solved this problem in 1943 by placing a
special flap under the wing where the
flow was not been affected by the shock
waves this flap could be deployed during
dives and would increase the lift on the
wing to maintain proper pitch control
over the next decade John continued his
work in the development of supersonic
flight and was a major driving force for
the development of the bell x-1 which
was the first manned vehicle to break
through the sound barrier in 1947 the
bell x-1 was a rocket-powered plane and
its fuselage was modeled after a 50
caliber round which was known to be
stable in supersonic flight its
engineers increased the critical Mach
number of the plane by using a very thin
wing and a
the pitch control issues of the p-38 by
raising the tail wing up and out of the
downstream airflow of the wing but this
plane still had a straight wing the
realization that the swept wing may hold
the key for high-speed flight came at
the end of World War two in 1951 the
balik's v was released and as design was
mostly based on a captured German
prototype the bell x5 had the special
ability to change its sweep angle during
flight making it the perfect test
subject to investigate the aerodynamic
advantages of the swept wing let's
compare the aerodynamics of the straight
wing bell x-1 and the balik's v as it
increases its sweep angle air over a
straight wing will flow parallel to the
cord only this is called a chord wise
flow the air that accelerates and
creates lift as explained earlier it is
this acceleration that reduces the
critical Mach number of the plane now
let's look at the flow over the bell x5
as it increases its sweep angle a swept
wing introduces a new component of flow
the span-wise flow this flow runs along
the length of the wing and does not
accelerate and thus does not affect the
critical Mach number by converting some
of the airflow into span-wise flow the
acceleration of air over the chord is
reduced this means the play can fly
faster before shock waves begin to form
over the wing as the plane increased in
speed the pilot could increase the sweep
angle doing this converted a larger
volume of air into span-wise flow and
thus increase the critical Mach number
even more this test proved that the
swept wing design could delay the
formation of shock waves and thus allow
planes to fly faster so next time you're
flying
take a look out the window and admire
the engineers of the early 20th century
their designs have allowed us to travel
across the globe at transonic speeds and
hopefully soon regular citizens may
break through the sound barrier once
again thanks for watching if you want to
learn more about the mechanics of the
swept wing click on my website here for
my next video I'll be discussing the
design of wind turbines please subscribe
and like our Facebook page below